Trump's floor is solid that's right yes
Trump's bottom end is locked in you are
like the Maga people I think so I mean I
don't think he works out you know the
mega people are are just they're not
going to change no matter what you I
mean he was right when he said you know
I could go out in Fifth Avenue and shoot
someone and they would still vote for
him that is still the case the people
that love Donald Trump love him to death
I don't think that uh I don't think that
that there's a whole lot of chance for
Joe Biden if it's split up between you
know between Kennedy and uh I forget
what his name is we were just talking
about him West West Seattle West I mean
though they will split the Democrat and
no I don't like Trump vote up and I
think enough where Trump would get in
now this is this is just talking a year
and a half or a year and change early so
obviously all this can change and this
is just my first impression but I I'm
confident that Donald Trump's floor
isn't changing